هجوم واسع بعشرات الصواريخ والطائرات
المسيره استهدف مناطق عديده في اوكرانيا
ما لا يقل عن 17 صاروخا ضربت مدينه
زابوريا جنوب شرق البلاد في ساعه واحده
حسب مسؤولين محليين الهجمات طالت محطات
الطاقه ومرافق نقلها في شرق اوكرانيا
وجنوبها وغربها ما تسبب في تعطيل
الامدادات كما تسببت في انفجارات في
العاصمه كيف ومناطق اخرى
سمعتم انفجارا ثم كيف تم تشغيل نظام
الدفاع المضاد للطائرات حوالي الساعه
العاشره صباحا سمعت صوت صاروخ ثم انفجار
ثم تحطمت جميع النوافذ وتضررت سيارات
عديده
رئيس بلديه كييف قال ان اوكرانيا اسقطت
عشره صواريخ روسيه في اجواء العاصمه حثن
السكان على البقاء في الملاجئ
عندما نكون في منازلنا فاننا نبقى في
الممرات ونراقب جهه قدوم الصواريخ كنت على
اتصال مع عائلتي لسوء الحظ هو صاروخ
بالقرب منهم
عند سماعنا صفارات الانذار بقينا نعمل في
مترو الانفاق فلدينا عمل مهم لا يمكن
الغائه وجاءت هذه الهجمات في اعقاب زياره
الرئيس الاوكراني الى خارج البلاد شملت
محادثات مع زعماء الاتحاد الاوروبي في
بروكسل بهدف تامين مزيد من الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا بما في ذلك الطائرات المقاتله